cuz it's a bucket list at the end you
put a full stop to these stunts that
they're never going to be this extreme
again cuz cuz then I'll be praying for
your divorce brother yeah I mean I'm not
prepared to throw in the towel the
question is am I going to try to get um
double d boobs in a boob job that and
I'm glad to bring this up for yourself
well yeah I'm I'm told to to not keep
them in for more than three months mons
because then the stretching just going
to be unmanageable but for let's say two
and a half months I could just have a
real go at seeing how much comedy I can
drum up with double de boobs man if you
put a pillow case over your head I'll
tit [__]
you idea is really dividing you know I'm
not my loved ones they're all pretty in
unison but but you know some people see
it some people don't and and I almost
think that I just have to do it